the defense secretary sacked after his
boss decided Gavin Williamson was behind
the leak of classified information from
the most secret meeting in Whitehall in
her letter the Prime Minister said there
was compelling evidence suggesting his
responsibility as she asked him to leave
her government blamed about a leak from
the sacrosanct national security council
over plans to allow Chinese company Y
way to build Britain's 5g mobile network
he refuted it last week and did so again
tonight saying i strenuously deny i was
in any way involved in this leak
not since the Profumo affair of 1963 has
a cabinet minister being sacked for a
national security breach this a
devastating fall from grace for a man
who went from new MP to defense
secretary in seven short years they'd
helped each other on the way up mr.
Williamson a kingmaker to mrs. may in
2016 he was richly rewarded lighted are
you to be chief with privilege are you
surprised
then he played a critical role in
getting the DUP to bat mrs. Mays
minority government and he was rewarded
again promoted to defense secretary he
believed he'd act as kingmaker to the
next p.m. tonight few MPs were defending
the former defence secretary if any
cabinet minister or anybody else who is
bound by the Official Secrets Act breaks
that oath then obviously they deserved
to be sacked you are deemed to have
signed the Official Secrets Act when you
become a minister
he's breached their act there's some
very high-profile civil servants who've
gone to jail for breaching that act and
I don't think that he should evade
investigation just because he's a
high-profile politician but the former
defence secretary told me tonight that
he would have wanted a police
investigation he said it would have
given him an opportunity to clear his
name because there was no evidence
against him he thinks that this was a
witch-hunt
from the start in his words a kangaroo
court with a summary execution number 10
say mr. Williamson Sakon is the end of
the matter for them and there will be no
police follow-up but it's not the end of
the matter for him mrs. Mays powerful
ally now an enemy on her back benchers
at the very moment she needs at least
Beth Rigby Sky News